Bravo Darth Maul on this [ __ ] just
very acrobatic no other [ __ ] dude in
the Star Wars universe had that many
Asian moves he was doing like triple
vacuums like [ __ ] chimney everyone
every other Sith Lord is old like
orthopedic shoes they can't fight what
you don't see under the robes he lifts
up his arms a little bit he's got a pair
of shape yo son is this Ross that Darth
Vader wasn't that wasn't the sound of
Darth Vader breathing yeah that was the
sound of his support shoes he got them a
Reebok [ __ ] air maxes with the air
pod in their falling over and [ __ ]
having new bounces and pleated khakis
this guy's a new lord like this yo is he
Russian he's like some type of Eurasian
because he's like he's athletic but that
[ __ ] is Asian this [ __ ] he's like you
know Russian but you know I'm saying
yeah cuz a lot of Gina's come on
auto-ship ruff-ruff yeah ruff any
problem in it you could dance to Darth
Maul just like kills 20 kids and then
dabs kids don't care
obi-wan kenobe kill try to kill he tried
to kill uh oh yeah a buddy somebody song
yeah yeah buddy somebody's on their
buddies on what's the name of the Star
Wars neighbors no yeah no he tried to
kill Luke spoiler alert
yeah because he's alright like that all
the time it doesn't matter
[Music]
is that gossip all these are gotten far
[Music]